voilà bon bout et lucien gainsbourg ne
dit rien donc avec tous les musiciens de
serge qui l'ont connu tout petit mousse
ou du piano c'est lui qui fait de bienne
voile appuie donc lui tout petit et
voilà il en plus longues on dit alors
pour commencer
c'était possible dans ces conditions là
sinon il aurait passé c'était scénic a
voulu préciser que six ans et il m'a dit
tu que je qu'on dise alors bousquet
interview dernier coup on ne bouge pas
dingle
on ne bouge pas pendant le qinghai
bien vous êtes déjà un peu romane super
ça va vous êtes très sage mes jambes
non mais quand ma fille est pas là c'est
plus simple de pas bouger parce qu'il a
il entraîne les autres en fait c'est
comme à l'école tu as des mecs qui
entraîne les autres
dernier coup dur toute l'année
ouais c'est comme ça c'est parti dans
les coups de bol dans les coups de tête
on trouve en vente en version d'asile
ah oui c'est vrai beaucoup d'importance
au vietnam ou pas pour toujours quand
même moi je vais partir dans les aides
allant momie avec la laventure fait
l'habitant se remet ça dans les coups de
coeur aulas est courant dans les coups
de poing sur lui
ah oui ah oui c'est à ce moment là on
n'a pas levé 8 chanel lemieux découvre
ça m'est arrivé je lui ai dit si tu
continues à l'école comme ça c'est coup
de boule maintenant à la sepaq coup de
poing ses coups de boule dernier coup de
foudre
serge dans les coups de gueule et coups
de fil à des coups de bluff midi dans
les coups de blues
on dernier comme nous c'était très
récemment et là c'est en train de
continuer un petit coup de blues dernier
couvre un couvent a laissé ce pas là
mais c'est vrai nom mais c'est vous
agite la non mais je sais mais vous
n'arrivez pas la remplacer
non je m'en vais j'essaie parfois chez
mon coeur et puis c'est mon coeur me dit
nyan win mais qui voudra quand même
wings et c'est pas mon problème ou ou
toujours une simple au non pas du tout
je suis loin d'être une simple ça c'est
clair
mais bon je vous dis ce qui se passe
bien
merci bonbons